[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos de visual política no es
ningún secreto la gran locomotora de los
eeuu está funcionando a toda velocidad
[Música]
tras 10 años de crecimiento interrumpido
la economía norteamericana vive un
momento fabuloso la tasa de desempleo se
encuentra por debajo del 4% lo que
supone el menor nivel desde el año 2000
cada mes que pasa se crean más de
100.000 nuevos empleos
los salarios crecen y tan sólo en los
últimos tres años se han creado casi 8
millones de puestos de trabajo además la
producción industrial el sp500 y las
exportaciones se encuentran en máximos
históricos
la locomotora vuela
sin embargo amigos esperando un momento
porque la economía de los eeuu también
tiene otra cara de la que ya os hemos
hablado aquí en visual político os dejo
el enlace al final de este vídeo y
también en la descripción
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno
queridos amigos la economía
norteamericana especialmente el gobierno
es adicta al crédito y a las deudas tal
cual como lo escucháis fijaos el pasado
30 de septiembre de 2018 marcó el cierre
del año presupuestario del gobierno
federal pues bien os hago una pregunta
sabríais decirme cuánto se incrementó la
deuda federal tan sólo durante este
ejercicio 80 centavos 500 700 800 850
870 ochocientos noventa
pues ni más ni menos que en 1,3 billones
de dólares billones en castellano-
trillones en inglés 13 billones en un
año una cantidad superior a todo el pib
de la economía mexicana web
vista entre sus tweets
fable exiguos estoy impresionado
under my nose si tienes
muy bien
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y ojo porque estamos hablando tan solo
del gobierno federal si la economía
crece pero es que el déficit público
está fuera de control durante el último
ejercicio con donald trump en la casa
blanca por cierto el gasto del gobierno
creció un 7% y las cosas parece que van
a ponerse bastante pero que bastante
peor la oficina de presupuestos del
congreso estima que hay que seguir por
este camino en menos de 10 años tan solo
el pago de intereses le costará al
gobierno federal más de 900 mil millones
de dólares cada año
sin embargo queridos amigos de visual
política el gobierno federal no es en
absoluto el único adicto a la deuda
atentos
[Música]
los estados la deuda oculta la economía
crece y los ingresos crecen en 2017 39
de los 50 estados que componen los
estados unidos han tenido superávit es
decir aparentemente han ingresado más de
lo que han gastado
[Música]
tras años de ajustes ahora la pregunta
que se hacen muchos gobernadores es cuál
es la mejor forma de gastar todo este
dinero
y ojo que desde el año 2010 la
recaudación de los estados se ha
incrementado en un 40% así que no
penséis que estamos hablando de unos
pocos centavos para nada por fin los
estados cuentan con recursos para
invertir en infraestructuras en
educación en servicios sociales suena
bien verdad lástima que la realidad sea
un poquito diferente bueno un poquito
completamente diferente
[Música]
en principio todos los estados a
excepción de vermont tienen el requisito
de tener un presupuesto equilibrado sin
embargo a pesar de ello y de todos los
aparentes superávits lo cierto es que
los estados no dejan de acumular deudas
obligaciones y pasivos de todo tipo de
hecho queridos amigos de visual política
a día de hoy los estados arrastran según
las estimaciones del 'think tank'
crucina counting una pesada carga de más
de 15 millones en deudas no financieras
[Música]
el resultado amigos es que la inmensa
mayoría ni más ni menos que 40 de los 50
estados no tienen recursos para
enfrentarse a todos los compromisos que
han adquirido pero un momento como
demonios pueden los estados a acumular
deuda y al mismo tiempo tener
equilibrados sus presupuestos pues
básicamente haciendo trampas contables
de todo tipo al fin y al cabo los
políticos son los primeros interesados
en enmascarar las cifras y gastarse
hasta el último centavo responsabilidad
presupuestaria a largo plazo pero vamos
a ver no os enteráis hay que ganar
elecciones
son muchas las trampas que se utilizan
desde inflar supuestos de ingresos hasta
retrasar el pago de facturas pero la
trampa más importante de todas es la que
tiene que ver con las pensiones y los
beneficios para los empleados públicos
que se jubilan
veréis me explico con el objetivo de
ganar votos y llevarse bien con los
sindicatos es habitual que los gobiernos
estatales prometan a los empleados
públicos unas pensiones muy buenas
además de un montón de beneficios
adicionales cuando se retiren
pues bien tal y como funciona el sistema
de pensiones en los eeuu se supone que
cada mes los gobiernos estatales deben
aportar a un fondo de pensiones las
cotizaciones las cantidades
comprometidas para que el día de mañana
todos estos trabajadores públicos puedan
cobrar las pensiones que les han
prometido
sin embargo amigos os voy a pedir que
nos pongamos un momento en el lugar de
los políticos que están a cargo de los
gobiernos estatales y si en vez de
ingresar todo ese dinero en un fondo de
pensiones lo dedicamos a todo tipo de
programas de gasto público de esta forma
podremos financiar muchos proyectos que
nos harán a su vez ganar más votos vale
puede que algunos de vosotros esté
pensando y qué ocurrirá cuando todos
esos empleados empiecen a jubilarse ya
reclamar sus pensiones y sus beneficios
cómo se les va a pagar y qué más da eres
político ese problema le va a tocar a
otro tú preocúpate de ganar tus
elecciones pues parece que a tenor de
los datos esta es la reflexión que se
han hecho muchos de los políticos
estatales los gobiernos estatales y
locales asumieron grandes compromisos
particularmente en materia de pensiones
y atención médica para jubilados pero no
financiero no adecuadamente esas
obligaciones
luke browning alcalde de hartford en
total tan sólo en lo concerniente a
pensiones no financiadas las deudas de
los estados superan ya el 28
dos mil millones de dólares la gran duda
es saber cómo diantres van a poder hacer
frente a toda esta enorme cantidad de
dinero claro que un momento no penséis
que todos los estados están en la misma
situación para nada atentos los mejores
y los peores vamos a ver si lo pensamos
un momento es fácil de comprender los
políticos tienen un incentivo gigantesco
a gastarse hasta el último centavo al
fin y al cabo todo su futuro depende de
las siguientes elecciones por eso es tan
importante absolutamente imprescindible
no sólo que existan contrapesos sino
también que la sociedad civil esté
atenta y sea muy exigente pero volvamos
al caso de los estados estadounidenses
tal y como hemos visto además de los
datos oficiales arrastran una colosal
deuda no financiada de 15 billones de
dólares ahora bien no todos los estados
se encuentran en la misma situación de
los 50 estados que tiene eeuu ni más ni
menos que 40 no tienen a día de hoy
activos suficientes como para hacer
frente a todas sus obligaciones por
supuesto algunos estados están mejor que
otros y en cualquier caso son 1010 los
estados cuyos políticos han sido lo
suficientemente responsables como para
garantizar el futuro del estado y
mantener unas cuentas ordenadas pues
bien estos son los 10 estados que han
hecho sus deberes si no hay dudas se han
ganado cuando menos el derecho a tener
una mención propia no os parece
estos son alaska dakota del norte
wyoming y utah dakota del sur idaho
tennessee nebraska oregón y iowa
como veis casi todos a excepción de
oregón y iowa son estados fuertemente
republicanos los demócratas deberían
empezar a fijarse en estas cosas
[Música]
el caso es que el resto todos los demás
estados tienen al día de hoy un balance
con números rojos claro que de todas
formas para que nos hagamos una idea de
lo que estamos hablando echemos un
vistazo al siguiente gráfico que recoge
los cinco mejores estados y los cinco
peores
[Música]
los datos están expresados en dólares
por contribuyente y si lo habéis visto
bien
[Música]
mientras estados como dakota del norte
de wyoming
han sido responsables y han acumulado
suficientes ahorros como para hacer
frente a todas sus obligaciones e
incluso contar con excelentes que podrán
ser invertidos en beneficio de cada
estado
illinois connecticut new yersey y
arrastran un terrorífico agujero de más
de 50 mil dólares por contribuyente
pero claro llegados a este punto la
pregunta es qué diantres van a hacer
todos estos estados para poder pagar sus
obligaciones la respuesta no es sencilla
porque la situación de algunos estados
como hemos visto es el caso de illinois
connecticut y new yersey es tan mala que
parece difícil encontrar una solución
[Música]
en el caso de nueva jersey y el estado
en peor situación de todos el agujero
fiscal en números contantes y sonantes
asciende a casi 200 mil millones de
dólares es decir que el agujero de un
estado que tiene poco más de 9 millones
de habitantes es más grande que la
economía de qatar y casi tan grande como
las economías de países como nueva
zelanda o perú de locos en cualquier
caso lo que sí podemos decir es que en
última instancia tan solo hay dos
caminos posibles o subir impuestos o
recortar el gasto
el problema es que subir impuestos puede
no ser ni siquiera una opción en tanto
en cuanto puede dañar el potencial
económico del estado y ahuyentar a
muchos contribuyentes especialmente a
las grandes fortunas eso es precisamente
lo que ha ocurrido en connecticut donde
durante los últimos años un montón de
grandes empresarios han huido del estado
por culpa de sus altísimos impuestos en
comparación con otros territorios de los
eeuu y no sólo en connecticut en 2016 el
último año del que tenemos datos 600.000
personas se movieron de los 25 estados
con los impuestos más altos a los 25
estados con los impuestos más bajos y
tras la última reforma fiscal de donald
trump es previsible que este proceso se
acelere pero amigos de todo esto
hablaremos en un próximo vídeo de
momento el caso es que como veis la
adicción por la deuda no es ni mucho
menos un problema exclusivo del gobierno
federal la economía de eeuu marcha
viento en popa pero a día de hoy está
la otra cara de la moneda
[Música]
lo cierto es que para que todo el
crecimiento que está teniendo el país
sea sostenible tanto el gobierno federal
como los gobiernos estatales tienen que
empezar de una vez por todas a tomarse
muy en serio todo el tema del déficit y
la deuda pública no es normal que un
país con un semejante crecimiento
experimente tantos desequilibrios en las
cuentas públicas no os parece que va a
ocurrir cuando vengan las cosas mal
dadas dónde está el límite a tanto
endeudamiento porque no lo olvidemos
tarde o temprano de una forma u otra la
deuda pública siempre siempre se termina
pagando si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante
no olvides darle al botón de like y
suscríbete a visual política si aún no
lo has hecho un saludo y hasta la
próxima
30 céntimos 500 700 800 50 870 890 800
[Música]